-Peter Sarsgaard.
I've known you for a long time.
-We've known each other
for a long time.
Yeah. Back in the day, with...
-Who were we hanging with?
-Julie Panebianco in the day.
-That's right. Julie Panebianco.
-We met a lot of
very cool people.
-I remember.
Were you sleeping on
someone's couch or something?
-I was. You know,
Julie knew Michael Stipe.
-Yeah, of course.
-She knew all
the cool rock stars.
I mean, we met
a lot of very cool people.
And Michael had
an apartment above her
and he was redoing it,
so there was nothing in it.
And she said, "You know,
I don't think he'd mind
if you stayed up there
for a little while."
-No way.
-So I stayed in that apartment
and I wanted to be respectful,
I remember, and I don't know,
it made sense at the time.
So I pitched a tent
in the apartment.
[ Laughter ]
He had no furniture, you know,
because he was going to
redo the apartment.
-So you lived in a tent
in Michael Stipe's apartment?
-I did, and he had all of
this really nice wine.
Well, I didn't know
it was really nice wine.
So, you know, you come up
and you'd be like,
"Well, I'll replace this one."
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
Wait, was he ever there?
-Michael was never there.
I got to know him
a little bit through Julie.
You know, there'd be
parties and things.
You'd see him around.
You and I, you know.
-Oh, yeah.
-We shook our money
makers here and there.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, we would hang out.
It was like
Michael Stipe and Bono.
-Bono.
-I mean, come on,
both those guys together.
And you sit there
and you go like...
-Well, I was at a party
with the two of them together,
and it wasn't a very big party.
And somebody put U2 on,
and I have this thing I'm like,
"I'm an air guitarist."
-Oh.
-As we all are,
if we've had
a few too many drinks.
-Yeah.
-And so I'm playing air guitar
to a U2 song with Bono, Michael
Stipe, not very far away.
And I remember very clearly
that Michael kind of walked over
to me and just went...
"No, no."
[ Laughter ]
-"No, no, just no. Don't do it.
No, no, please.
Bono's right over --"
-It's very subtle.
He's like, "Peter. Peter.
No, no."
-Yes, very quiet.
In front of Bono.
-Insanely embarrassing.
-I don't know if I've ever
seen you play air guitar.
-My children have seen me
air guitar.
-Would you air guitar right now
if the Roots played something
right now?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just anything. You got a jam?
-Where's my light?
♪♪
Where's my light?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow.
Wow!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh.
He threw his guitar.
He threw his guitar
and someone caught it.
Thank goodness.
-That's my homage to Prince.
-Thank you for doing that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't ever want to make anyone
ever do anything on my show,
but that was fantastic.
Thank you for doing that.
-I could've gone on
for much longer.
-Let's talk about
your new film, "Memory."
-Why not?
-You're getting great reviews.
In fact, buddy,
you won Best Actor
at the Venice Film Festival.
Come on, that's not too shabby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that.
-That is a --
It's like they're
pranking you with this award.
Do you see how big this is?
-Giant. Yes.
-I love this film.
I loved it since I got it.
Jessica Chastain.
-You were phenomenal.
Oh, you and Jessica Chastain.
You know what I compare it to?
It's like watching two --
It's like watching
Roger Federer
play Roger Federer.
It's like two awesome
people at their best.
And you're just so much fun
to just watch.
Even though the subject matter
isn't the most fun thing,
but it's like two --
-No, I mean,
but here's the thing.
It isn't the most fun thing.
Look, she has serious trauma
in her life
that she's dealing with.
And I play a guy
with early onset dementia.
So she's got all this stuff
that she can't forget
and I can't remember anything.
-Yeah. It kind of fits.
-Actually a perfect couple.
-It's a beautiful movie.
-She tells me about her trauma.
Then the next day
we get together
and I don't remember any of it.
-Yeah, no.
Yeah. It's just so -- You play
it so well. It's heartbreaking.
It's beautiful.
It's well done.
The director again?
-Michel Franco.
Yeah.
-It's -- Yeah.
You'll love this movie.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Peter Sarsgaard
in "Memory."
Take a look at this.
-Hi. Welcome back.
Can I get you anything to drink?
-I'll have some water, please.
-The usual for you?
-Hm?
-The usual?
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh.
-What's the usual?
-I don't know.
-[ Chuckles ] You don't --
-No.
-Do you remember her?
-Okay.
-I don't think I know her.
-But you do remember
that the food is good.
-Oh, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's memorable.
-Yeah. It's like, "The usual?"
"Yes, of course."
Peter Sarsgaard, everybody.
"Memory" opens
in select theaters
December 22nd,
nationwide January 5th.
Chef Daniel Humm
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.